yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
lucky against my nemesis auriga's Miriam
peculiar plan on my CC yeah i hope that
i do a relatively decent job here
because I tried to play yesterday after
a very long day at work and it didn't
didn't work at all I lost like five or
six I don't know yeah warm-up games
straight and miss you see my rating it's
completely wrecked and yeah so I'm
trying again now in the morning which I
usually am don't do it but I'd like to
keep them the videos so yeah I'd like to
keep a steady flow of videos ok so let's
see what happens here ya allah gases sir
i'm an endgame specialist and we have a
very end game type of position here well
yeah it's um this line is not promising
wide that much but it's very safe and
you can always try for for a little bit
i'm going to e6 here with my night
that's not a bad post his son yeah i
thought 96 @ x @ xt for so he needs to
react to that and then i play cyf that
was my idea at least ok so no like a
bishop of six and we have forgot not too
bad
sugar 6 is not too bad I think and maybe
he's night f form yeah well I can take
before anyway if he goes Roxy six yeah
maybe I should have played it a bit
differently I actually now intended
Bishop before but his card rook takes a
six this is a bit of a shame now I can
take on g4 with the night and I need to
I don't have any alternative you can
take ruger six now now all that one
which also gives white some some edge
simply because of the isolated pawn it's
not the end of the world but its own
it's not very comfortable I should hope
this and I would hold it in a normal
time game but in a blitz game white can
always try try to poke around in this in
this position trying to get some counter
play in
mmm ok it's maybe going to deform when a
4 is going to play before I am
yeah if I was probably not exactly great
mmm yeah it's very difficult to to even
keep keep any anything here can deform
dumb
yeah if I was stupid okay but it's a
very uncomfortable opponent anyway if
you just have left the bed
yeah well his main strategy in those end
games anyway is to move quickly and went
on time he's the kind of person who
plays every position on time Luke
against Luke everything Ryan this again
I don't know don't I get h for now I
don't turn I just see how I know okay I
get it and it's completely ok again this
position so my drug three two one okay
if I go g6 some he will probably am
clicking f6 I don't want that check
check
in our King to c 6
yeah I'm not sure I mean obviously I'm
worse but is it still a draw yeah it's
not the kind of position where you can
say em it's just the draw oh it's it's
just a win check you can simply a play
on of course because what is better you
would also play on if if he's I don't
know whatever position it so it doesn't
matter to him oops that's my radio
starting in the background I'm sorry
I cannot switch it off right now it's
another room so I hope it doesn't
irritate too much so it's a very reduced
material
rook v6 King f6 King b5 checkers and his
trick so we'll get rook against Luke
here I think and check and you will play
this on time check obviously it will
never agree a draw here grawr check it
causes some chat 20 seconds and check
will play on time morning check check
check
check check and i roped you five i
missed this check check check check
check as mentioned before she is just a
complete idiot but what can you do check
check check check black what it's on
time yeah that's the way he gets his
points no I he just plays on every crap
position and well yeah then let's
document it on video what can you do all
right not a very enjoyable experience
but what what else can i say i don't
think you enjoyed it too much but this
is why we shouldn't play any chess
without increments unfortunately i see
has not yet implemented it in and those
some auto pairing games and this means
that the skype is constantly higher
rated than he deserves because of this
nonsense but whatever i hope you got
something out of this video not quite
sure what but thanks and see you again
with new videos